[Music]
well here's why I wrote big guns I had
served in Congress for 16 years and in
those 16 years
I witnessed shooting at a university in
Virginia shooting at a movie theater in
Aurora Colorado shooting at a nightclub
in Orlando shooting at an elementary
school in Connecticut and after every
single one of those mass shootings I and
every one of my colleagues were
confronted with the same question and
that is when is Congress going to do
something about it
when will is stop not necessarily when
will Congress do everything about it but
just do something do universal
background checks or some common-sense
legislation and when my constituents in
New York would ask that question I knew
that the honest answer and the painful
answer was we're not Congress is not
going to do anything because of the
politics that surrounded the gun safety
debate and I decided to try and answer
that question in the best way I can and
that is with snork with humor and from
the very inside of Congress I wrote this
book during hearings on gun safety I
wrote this book on the floor of the
House of Representatives I wrote this
book on that little balcony off the
floor of the House of Representatives
where members go to rest while they're
not beating each other up inside and so
this book is really--it's a reflection
of what I learned as a member of
Congress and it is my way of explaining
to readers why Congress seemed so
paralyzed in the face of this massive
violence that is affecting so many
communities and so many of our
constituents 90% of the American people
support strengthen background checks
about 80% of Republicans support
strengthen background checks a majority
of NRA members support strengthen
background checks and yet when we
offered this amendment for stronger
background checks in the Appropriations
Committee it was defeated virtually in a
party-line vote and I was wrestling with
this why would members of Congress vote
against something that has such massive
support well I learned the lesson and
the lesson is reflected in big guns
after that
hearing I went to one of the most sacred
places on Capitol Hill not a church but
the members only elevator and the reason
it's sacred is because on the members
only elevator you can't have tourists in
can't have the media in can't have staff
in and so you reach a real level of
confidentiality in that cramped space
and a bunch of members piled onto this
elevator after the committee meeting and
one of the Republicans on this elevator
said why did you try and force us to
vote for you know for this amendment for
background checks and I said well we
didn't force you to do anything you
voted against it my question to you is
why would you vote against it and this
member looked at me and said I wanted to
vote for it but I can't go home and
explain that vote to my gun lobby voters
it would be the end of my career that
tells you everything you need to know
about why Congress seems so paralyzed
let's just say one other thing on this
after every mass shooting the entire
country is galvanized they want to
mobilize I mean think about what
happened after Parkland you know we it
was so certain that Congress was going
to pass something there were rallies and
marches and you know everybody was
talking about it
but now we're months from parkland and
what does Congress done nothing I wrote
this book so Congress people will be
reminded that the solution to this is in
the Congress and they have to keep
pressuring their members of Congress to
pass meaningful reforms that will make
our kids safer I did not want to write
big guns as my personal screed against
the the NRA and the gun lobby I thought
the best and most credible way of
writing this book was to bring different
characters in with different viewpoints
and by the way that's what Congress is
like it's different characters with
different viewpoints and I felt that the
best way to tell this story was as a
satire but you know all satire has to be
based on a kernel of truth and the truth
in this book is the fact that Congress
does nothing the book was actually based
on an extraordinary and a shocking event
after the Sandy Hook massacre that that
killed children in this elementary
school in Connecticut I was reading a
sitting having breakfast right after
that I was so convinced that we in
Congress were finally going to do
something
when first graders are gunned down it
would seem that Congress would do
something and my confidence was really
high and I was having breakfast and I
was reading my New York Times one
morning I came upon this article and I
could have sworn that the New York Times
had been infiltrated by the writers of
the onion because it seems so bizarre
the story was that while most state and
local governments were actually passing
local ordinances for gun safety because
Congress would do nothing the small city
of Nelson Georgia decided that they
would go in a different direction
this small City passed a local ordinance
requiring that every resident of the
city must possess a firearm and that was
my kernel of truth and when I saw that I
said first I had to figure out whether
it was actually true and then when I
realized that it was true I decided to
build a satire around this only instead
of making it applicable to one small
city in Georgia I federalized it I
create this law that requires that every
American must own a firearm that works
its way through Congress now if I had
just written about the process it would
be a maybe a slightly lighter version of
the Congressional Record still very
boring and so I decided I had to weave
into it real characters and I had to
make sure that the characters express
different viewpoints because the gun
debate is is influenced by so many
different viewpoints so it was important
to me that this story reflect both sides
of the issue but also make the point
that Congress will not act because of
the politics that surrounds us and the
fear that so many of my colleagues have
not that their constituents are going to
be shot but that their careers may be
ended if they take on the gun Ra in the
gun lobby
[Music]